Consciousness as perhaps the biggest readily nature strip too.
It's cool meaning consciousness is what allows us to be aware both of our
surroundings and of our own in a state,
but thinking about consciousness has this habit of taking us around in circles.
We all intuitively know what consciousness is.
It's this,
it's what you're experiencing here right now,
but once we tried to pinpoint just what exactly it is,
it leaves this grasping at thin air and not just us.
Philosophers and scientists struggle to define consciousness.
Different schools and ideas compete with one another,
but no one has come close to figuring it out.
It's unsettling to realize that we don't understand what makes us aware of
ourselves and the world
in this fuzzy area.
Consciousness and intelligence are also related,
although they are not the same.
We'll talk in greater depth about theories of consciousness and intelligence in
other videos like much of what makes us human.
Our consciousness is likely to have evolved from less complex forms.
As a product of evolution by natural selection,
it has probably emerged from an immense several hundred million years sequence
of countless micro steps that together make up a sort of gradient of
consciousness.
What was the first step on this path for the nonconscious to the basic
consciousness that ultimately led to the convoluted consciousness we humans
enjoy today?
Take a stone.
The consensus is that a stone is not conscious though not everyone agrees.
Even on this,
some pans,
cyclists claimed that a lump of rock may have an inner life.
However,
there are no real grounds for any such assumption since stones never show
behavior that in a life can neither be proven nor disproven.
More common starting point is with the living things and living thing or a self
is a part of the universe that sustains itself and makes more of its kind to do
so.
It needs energy and this is where an awareness of the world comes in handy.
The original function of consciousness was probably to direct to a mobile self
that was short of energy to a fresh supply of food.
On the smaller scales of life.
You don't need to be aware to find food.
Trico plaques adherence,
one of the simplest of all animals moves around haphazardly.
It slows down in the presence of food and speeds up and its absence.
This is highly effective and makes the tiny creature spend more time where there
is food than where there is not,
but it never moves in a particular direction towards a particular target and
there's no need for it to be conscious of its environment.
The first major step towards consciousness was probably taken when mobile selves
started to move themselves directionally moving towards what was good for them,
save food and away from what was less good.
Say someone else who thought that they were food.
Take ECR to greener.
A tiny worm known for it's funny face.
Sometimes the worm is hungry and sometimes not.
This means that when it moves,
the worm self is not simply producing an automatic response to an external
stimulus,
but that it's actions depend upon its inner physiological state,
whether it's hungry or sate it
when it's just eaten,
the worm is less energetic,
but when staff for awhile it will move itself in the direction of tasty things.
It uses chemo receptors on its head to smell it's environment and guided in the
direction whether center food is strongest after finding and eating a meal,
our one buddy heads back to a dark sheltered spot to digest it in safety until
it's hungry again.
But animals that blindly follow their sense of smell don't have a concrete
objective in view.
They still lack any sense of where they are heading.
So the next step on the ladder of consciousness is to add some perception at a
distance like vision,
vision adds context and depth to our world.
With vision comes a sense of the space we and our food existed.
It adds a whole new dimension to awareness and is a huge step towards more
familiar consciousness.
An optical operators like an eye enables us to visualize our goal and lock onto
it,
but even at this stage,
a self is only able to pursue its food as long as it sees it.
So the next logical step needs to happen on the inside to visualize food in its
absence.
For example,
herself needs to create some sort of inner representation of the world.
Now an animal can continue looking for food even when it escapes sits sensory
range.
Because of this inner representation of what is relevant in the world,
it can remain focused on its food and its desire to get it ourself now exists in
a world it can get familiar with the ability to remember things has emerged
thanks to memory.
Animals can be distracted from a pursuit for a few but quickly continue their
path afterwards.
A related phenomenon is called object permanence.
This describes our awareness that things continue to exist even when we can't
see them.
This cognitive skill is enjoyed by some mammals and birds and perhaps other
animals to human babies tend to develop this ability around the time they turn
eight months.
While baby chickens show visibility within a day or two of being born,
the capacity to remember a thing and its absence suggests at least a basic sense
of time.
A sense of time is a big step on a ladder of consciousness.
It may also enable herself to look forward from the present moment and
anticipate the future.
Adult chickens,
for example,
are able to resist a meal put in front of them if they expect to receive a
bigger meal as a prize for holding back for a while.
This sort of delayed gratification means there is an ability to visualize a
reward that only exist in the future,
which can be quite a challenge even for adult humans.
Western Scrub Jays are experts in delayed gratification.
They show an even more elaborate sense of the future when they hide food and a
cache to retrieve it at a later date.
The Scrub Jays will even rehydrate their food if they become aware that a
potential thief has been watching them.
This means that they know that there are other hungry selves out there who are
aware and see the world from their own different perspective.
Crafty Scrub Jays can sort of read the mind of their fellow birds.
Visibility to mind read is crucial for complex levels of consciousness.
By putting yourself in the position of others,
you could out smarter rich competitor or empathize with a hungry friend.
Language takes the ability to read minds and represent what is absence to a
whole new level.
Words enabled us to construct hypotheses about the world,
make detailed plans,
and to communicate them with others.
Words,
enablers to think about ourselves and our place in the universe and even about
our own consciousness,
which is something we'll be doing more in future videos.
So what is the origin of our consciousness?
It probably began as the directed motion of a hungry self towards a source of
food with the survival benefits.
This gave it over competitors that moved at random all,
not at all.
It probably all started with the urge for more food.
So even with the sophisticated consciousness that allows us to dream about
space,
build skyscrapers,
or obsess about novels,
it's not surprising that we can't stop thinking about where we'll get our next
meal.
Collectively,
we've put so much thought and ingenuity and to getting food that we can now just
get our food to come to us with little conscious effort.
This video is part one of a three part video series relating to big questions of
life and the universe made possible by a grant from the Templeton World Charity
Foundation.
You can find our sources and further reading in the video description or get the
consciousness book by Rupert Glasgow for free.
Link down below.
If you want to help us make more videos,
you can do so on patrion.com or get one of our posters from our shop.